the u.s. Civil War ended over 150 years
ago at least officially but the
Confederacy went on to fight another day
on the cultural front its flag and
historical figures have become an
essential part of many Americans
identity but it seems the time has come
for its last stand can you imagine
Jefferson Davis Alexander Stephens
treason they committed treason against
the United States of America and their
statutes are still here because their
states put them here robert e lee
Jefferson Davis and Alexander Stevens
actually have statues within the US
Capitol building
but now the call is coming for those
statues to finally be removed 150 years
later the possibility has never been so
real Confederate statues and monuments
still pay tribute to white supremacy and
slavery in public spaces it is time to
tell the truth about what these statues
are hateful symbols that have no place
in our society and certainly should not
be enshrined in the US Capitol the
Confederate flag is a symbol that many
southerners as well as even low-income
whites in other parts of the country
have come to identify with but now the
declaration is coming from the halls of
power saying that it's time for this to
come to an end the US military with the
backing of the US Senate is talking
about changing the name of bases named
after Confederates this does not sit
well with the president it has been
suggested that we should rename as many
as 10 of our legendary military bases my
administration will not even consider
the renaming of these magnificent and
fabled military installations as the
most diverse and integrated part of
American society it is only right there
our installations bear the names of
military heroes who represent the best
ideals of our republic all across the
country Confederate monuments are being
beheaded toppled and there's a friendly
map to help you plan your next target
NASCAR has banned the displaying of
Confederate flags at the racetrack the
presence of the Confederate flag at
NASCAR events runs contrary to our
commitment to providing a welcoming and
inclusive environment for all our
ants our competitors and our industry
the display of the Confederate flag will
be prohibited from all NASCAR events and
properties a film that has long been
considered to be a classic of American
cinema is no longer available on HBO
Mack's gone with the wind has captured
the imagination and acclaim of the
entire world
the Confederacy was defeated in 1865 the
US Constitution outlaws the practice of
slavery due to an amendment furthermore
robert e lee's ranch has been converted
into Arlington National Cemetery so why
are Americans still clashing over a war
that ended over 150 years ago I
understand what many people are
pessimistic about the future of the
United States of America because this
Civil War has not really ended it is
continuing under a different guise and
it would not be outlandish to suggest
let the opponents of tearing down these
statues objectively or pushing for kind
of second-class third-class
citizenship if that were black Americans
and for any people not defined as white
and as long as that kind of pernicious
ideology persists there will be a
simmering civil war in the United States
of America as we saw in Charlottesville
two years ago and elsewhere in other
parts of the country many Americans have
a strong emotional attachment to these
Confederate symbols and they're willing
to fight back with one side being
branded as Nazis and the other side
being branded as domestic terrorists
civil tensions are high at this point
they're set to flare up even further as
the war against honoring the Confederacy
rolls on Kaleb Maupin RT New York
you